oh
from the unemployment rate
other Publications probably
please
I would appreciate that
I'm gonna open up the executive session
on House Bill 190 FN
relative duration of unemployment
benefits and recognized representative
seaworth for emotion
thank you Mr chairman I move we retain
this bill
motion is to retains moved and seconded
uh by excuse me moved by representative
seaworth second Vice representative
avalani representative seaworth
I'm still getting settled so I'll let
somebody else why don't you just wave to
me
so um
this bill
is in second rendition first submitted
last year the goal is to reduce the
amount of unemployment benefits someone
receives
based on the unemployment rate
this was based off of
another state that was successful
utilizing this
but I think it's been very clear to all
of us it would not be successful I see
you Josh can you put your hand down
it's very sick this is not
uh something that would work here
in New Hampshire
um or any number of reasons
that New Hampshire does better than the
state that enacted it on almost every
parameter and every uh everything worth
of calculating
the
sponsor
understands that
however does have a concern
that there are a number of people
staying on unemployment through the
first 26 weeks
uh through the for through all the 26
weeks
and would like to
make a significant change to the bill I
have spoken
at length with this uh with the
assistant commissioner lovers about what
other things are available
um that he sees around the country
that we might be able to step up
um
not only not just for the purpose of
getting people off but getting them a
job which is appropriate for them
um he understands what my goal is and um
that is why I'm asking you to retain it
and I'll say it a second time
in front of people
on record in front of the cameras
that is not the intent to bring this
bill back in any in its same form where
it would be reducing
unemployment benefit weeks based on
a um
percentage on on the uh unemployment
rate
that's why I've asked the retention
representative attitude
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to
oppose retention
um because I believe itl is a more
appropriate motion and beyond that I
think indefinite postponement is a more
appropriate emotion and the only reason
I stop at indefinite postponement
because there isn't a higher means to
kill this film
um
I have never seen uh the employment
security folks give such a passionate
and thorough defense of an already well
functioning
unemployment system than they did when
this bill was introduced as we said for
the second time
this bill relies on a philosophy that
the biggest issue that we faced during
the last two years and the covid
pandemic was that in the middle of the
biggest Health crisis that this country
has faced in over a hundred years that
the real problem was that people just
had it too good with unemployment and
that was the argument that we heard
breathlessly two years ago when it was
lobbied that we reduce extended
unemployment benefits uh in the state of
New Hampshire did in June of 2021 uh and
since that time we have not seen the
kind of major filling of job vacancies
that was projected to happen we all saw
the story the other week where due to
these significant Staffing shortages
to the state prison uh the National
Guard now has to come in and fill spots
as an employee of the Dartmouth Health
Network I can say that reducing those
unemployment benefits did not change the
fact that our nursing stations
have about 150 slots to fill a week and
have about 80 people's Worth to do it
um these sectors are still woefully
um undone even with that rollback and
extended unemployment I don't think this
is going to do anything different
um I would really like to see
um this bill meet its end on the floor
uh and as such I will oppose retaining
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair I I agree with you
that this is not necessary for New
Hampshire and I question what the other
bill that the representative from
Barrington is thinking about certainly
it sounds like it's a different bill so
he would be free to introduce that bill
for next year
so I'm inclined to vote ICL on this
version of Sullivan
um
I'm going to vote Yes on retain
I told you Mr chair that I would do that
um I do not agree with anyone who's said
that this is a horrible bill in its
present form if we get another bill that
is anywhere near as bad as this one
um I will see to it that that bill goes
down uh next year but uh
um I just want to be clear that um when
I record my vote Yes it's not because I
think this bill
um is in any way attractive or that we
necessarily need any bill
um
because I think uh Deputy Commissioner
labors did an excellent job of showing
um how well our unemployment system is
working now
so um but but you will have my vote Mr
chair
worth
thank you Mr chairman um I was not part
of the discussions that you had about
maybe some appropriate changes to this
bill something that came to my mind
certainly I'm very proud of the
um impact that our unemployment system
has in New Hampshire
I think it's working very well the the
statistics show that I don't think we
can sit here and say Well it must be
perfect then
when I listened to the testimony on this
bill there was the sponsor brought up
just one person it was an example of
an employee that is off seasonally and
is off seasonally every year and it
sounded from the story for a significant
amount of time after that I spoke to the
Deputy Commissioner
and he explained to me that there are in
fact certain employers that never pay
into the system as much as they end up
having their employees take out
so for me that was one example of
um maybe a problem that was addressed
addressed by the sponsor and there may
be a solution that would have bipartisan
support
so that's why I'm supporting the chair
in his effort to
retain this bill and use that as a
vehicle to do a little more work on this
subject thank you
representative McKenzie thank you Mr
chairman
um
I served on the unemployment advisory
committee for many years as as you do
currently
there were a lot of changes I think that
we could make in the unemployment system
and I would I would be more than happy
to work on any bill that relates to that
the problem I have with this legislation
this particular bill is when I queried
the sponsor of the bill as to who wrote
this bill
it was not written by anybody in New
Hampshire it was written by a National
Organization who has no particular
interests in improving the benefits of
the unemployed workers in the state of
New Hampshire
and therefore I I think if it is uh
we're waiting for another version from
the same organization who produces
um that's somewhat troubling to me
but that said I think we need to we need
uh we need to work on the unemployment
system the benefits could be improved
they haven't been for a number of years
uh and there are other things we may be
able to do but I don't see necessarily
listens as a vehicle to do that and I
would uh and I will vote against uh any
motion to keep this bill alive
yeah
all right seeing no further hands
we have a motion on the floor
to retain house bill 190.
which has been made in a second we've
had our discussion
Clerk
if you are in favor of retain your vote
Yes if you were against your vote no
we'll make
on the roll Vice chair seaworth yes
rep avaloni yes
yes rep bogert
yes
rep love
ter oh
rep Boyd yes
rep Mason yes
rep Cole come
yes
rep sellers
rep done yes
pranking them Sullivan yes
rep Murray
no
rep Cahill no
rep Delorenzo
no
rep Susie
Brett Bouchard no
rep agitant
Brett McKenzie no
the clerk votes no
rep Leclair no
and Mr chair yes
10 years nine Nays we recognized for a
motion of Ito
I think she said ten and nine ten years
nine Nays and one not voting
so it passed
it's retained I don't know how that math
worked out but it did you sure
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten one two three four five six
seven eight nine
everybody voted except for rap love
so that is a that is a total of 20 votes
do you have all your positions no
he's late
I mean I did a little count thing all
right so I thought it was my apologies
yeah I thought it was so weird
that's weird
my apologies
moving on
House Bill 232
adopt section 1019 OSHA standards for
public sector employees in New Hampshire
representative Sullivan you recognize
for emotion
I moved to retain
um house bill 232.
which has been made by Sullivan
second by Smith
Susie I'm sorry Tim
Sullivan you're
recognized
thank you
um this um this bill is uh intended to
replace the uh New Hampshire Department
of Labor's health and safety standards
with the OSHA standards
um numbered uh 1910.
um
the uh we
heard
um
testimony and during our subcommittee
meetings that there were
various uh organizations and groups that
really wanted to weigh in and do some
more direct comparisons as to uh
what the two standards are um the
department of labor standards and the
OSHA standards are so um out of
deference to them they did not have a
chance during our
study committee to uh to weigh in and I
think the subcommittee felt it was
vulnerably reasonable for us to continue
to
um meet on a retained bill
um and get those folks an opportunity to
do the work that they wanted to do so
for that reason the subcommittee
decided unanimously that retaining the
bill was the right course of action to
take and my
hopes and expectations are that we will
continue to work on this in come January
of next year we'll have a vote on this
and successfully adopt the OSHA
standards so uh
that's that
I think Robertson Sullivan their
representative Abalone and Susie
um
you're on the committee any comments
no I just I'll agree with Brian I think
there's a lot of work that went into
this bill over the last couple years
I think it's a good bill
um but I agree that you know there are
some tweaks that need to be made and
give people time so I think it's a good
idea to retain it thank you
any other comments
thank you Mr chairman um having served
in this committee um
the
discussion of cost has come um to the
Forefront
um given the where people are into where
this is going to take us
um so
um I agree with the retain and let's
work on it some more with the people
that are
nervous
I agree as well
anyone else like to speak on this motion
motion on the floor is routine
brought by uh representative Sullivan
second by representative Susie
you are in favor you will be saying yes
to your opposed and saying no
but I'm clerk please call the roll Vice
chair seaworth yes rep avaloni yeah
Brett bogert
yes
rep love
still not here
rep Boyd yes
rep Mason yes Repco yes
rep sellers yes rep done yes
ranking damn Sullivan yes
Rhett Murray yes
rep K Hill yes
prep De Lorenzo yes
rep Susie yes
Brett Bouchard yes
rep agent
Rhett McKenzie yes
the clerk votes yes
uh Rhett McClure Claire yes you're good
and Mr chair yes
that's 18 years and one name and one not
one
we now have to take about nine minutes
here
um
before we have our next
session in case people want to be here
to have it so
sit tight for the next eight or nine
minutes
we shall return
thank you
my namesake's not even over there
can I get booted
it is 2 30 I'm turning over the chair
on this um
on this bill to rep Vice chairman
seaworth
um
yeah for reasons you'll see shortly
representative seaworth thank you uh so
we'll begin the executive session on HB
182 and I will recognize uh
representative infantine for a motion
Mr chairman I uh move
Amendment 2023099h
say it again on House Bill 182
did you repeat the amendment number for
the clerk zero nine nine zero H everyone
should have a copy in front of them
is there a second second
made and seconded you were recognized to
speak to your Amendment thank you
Mr chairman as you know excuse me I'm
not comfortable with the bill the way it
is I'm trying to submit
some amendments
that I feel are appropriate
in the testimony that was provided
it was outlined that
the firefighters volunteer firefighters
should have
um the right
that is already given to members of the
uh ambulance and EMT
and that was outlined in
section excuse me in RSA 153 a17.
and if you read
section 153 a17 it really doesn't say
what this bill says at all
so
what I've done is I copied it
pretty much line for line word for word
but instead of having
just emergency medical workers it
includes volunteer firefighters
and it states that no volunteer
firefighter was in good faith attempts
to render firefighting and emergency
service on their way on the route to an
employment they will not receive any
form of reprimander penalty as a result
of their of this
so if you truly want to give
the same right to the father of
firefighters is already in law
on 153 a17
then that's what this amendment does
further discussion
representative adjectives
thank you Mr chairman um I will be
opposing this amendment
um for a few reasons
um
while I appreciate the effort to copy
the EMT statute what that says to me is
that we need to expand the EMT statute
um
three uh zero zero excuse me zero nine
nine zero H
um only pertains to a volunteer
firefighter who
hopefully the emergency happens while
they're on their way to work
um otherwise there's no protection
extended to them
um
uh there are a lot of small towns in the
state of New Hampshire that rely on
their volunteer firefighting Force
um
I would prefer that volunteer
firefighters got paid I think it's very
hard and dangerous work that they do
that potentially has a lot of long-term
Health consequences the original bill as
written for me is the compromise
um
I I I I really think that you know if it
was your house or the house of somebody
that you cared about uh that burned down
in the middle of a work day and somebody
couldn't get there because they were
stuck at Walmart because they're um
shift lead wouldn't let them off you'd
feel really pretty rubbed raw by that
during the pandemic I actually uh did
senior in-home caretaking for two
individuals uh who one was very
cognitively disabled the other one was
very physically disabled and if a fire
had occurred
um at a moment where somebody wasn't
immediately in the area to get them out
they wouldn't have made it out of that
building
um and it haunts me to think uh
something like that happening because an
employee is stuck at work uh this bill
doesn't deal with that so for that
reason on top of the fact that
as representative Sullivan alluded to in
earlier conversations
um this still allows for some discipline
um I'm very concerned with that
my goal with this legislation is to
extend these same protections to
volunteer firefighters and EMS workers
that are granted currently to our
Reserve troops I think that's a fair
standard and as such I will be opposing
this amendment
further discussion
representative
I would just like to ask for some
clarification from the previous
representative you said that volunteer
firefighters do not get paid is that
correct did I understand you correctly
on that
I'm not going to speak for every single
Department across the state of New
Hampshire it's my understanding that if
they're volunteered they're not getting
paid
um
that's
further further discussion uh
representative McKenzie well I just uh I
don't have specific data on that but I
can tell you that uh the volunteer
firefighters do get paid in many
communities
um and they have a set amount of money
they get paid and they're also entitled
to workers compensation as a result of
the pain that they receive
thank you yes uh representative yeah I
just want to clarify I I would I I would
hope that that would not be the sticking
point of my argument I'm happy to be
wrong on that
um but my point um there more broadly
was I think this amendment to two
Narrows down what is already a
compromised position for me
um so that's why I'll be opposing it
any further comments
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
on Amendment zero nine nine zero h
um
thank you Mr chair
yes
rep avaloni
Brett bogert yes rep love
rep Boyd yes
rep Mason yes
rep sellers yes
rep done yes
ranking them Sullivan no
rep Murray no
rep Cahill no
reptilorenzo no
prep Susie no
wrote Bouchard no
rep adjectives no
Rick McKenzie no
the clerk votes no replicator no
and Mr Vice chair yes
that is a vote of 10 to 10.
so that motion to amend fails did I see
you had another amendment you wanted to
bring forth
Mr chairman I I bring forth
Amendment 2023
-0979h
the motion to amend has been made did
you get that number I did
zero nine is there a second second
in a second about it
thank you
um would you do you wish to speak I wish
please do the first one first amendment
I was trying to make a point
right because
it was said time and time again that the
firefighters uh volunteer firefighters
deserve the same
uh benefit that is given in law
by the emergency medical
folks so I made that point to do exactly
what was said
knowing full well
it was not going to be enough but it's
on the record that is exactly what was
requested at least verbally
this one is more of what I consider a
compromise representative attitude
so what I did here is I made some
changes
to both the the beginning part
of the bill as well as out of the second
at the line 16 17-18
there is a belief that
you shouldn't be able to be discharged
or disciplined
for certain actions
and it seems to be pervasive and the
reason why I will never ever give anyone
a pass
or discharge
or reprimand goes back to
10 years ago you can look this up while
I'm talking about it
when a University of New Hampshire
professor
exposed himself to a 16 year old girl
and her mother in a parking lot
of a grocery store
he was arrested
fired
and then received his job back with full
pay and benefits
through an arbitration clause and and
the the
arbiter
so no one gets a free pass for anything
because there's always things you cannot
expect
this says you cannot discharge someone
for failure to to show up
doesn't say reprimand and I understand
that's a sticking point with some people
but for me this was a major compromise
to allow the non-discharge
further down in line 16 17 and 18.
there needs to be some kind of mechanism
where the employer can say no sorry not
today
something Big's going on we have a
container that's coming that has to be
removed you are the one it person and
you have to turn over the computers
today something could possibly be
happening which would they would the
employer would have to say no or tell
you two weeks in advance I'm sorry next
Friday we have something going on
you can't do this now
I took it upon myself to speak with two
Fire Chiefs
one who has full-time employees
who off the Record doesn't like this
bill as written
and I couldn't think why
I was amazed when he finally told me why
because he has individuals who are also
full-time firefighters and volunteer
firefighters in their towns
and when they can't show off he has to
pay overtime to get someone to stay on
their shift
never even thought of that
talk to another fire chief who was a
chief of a volunteer fire department out
in the Peterborough area
and I said what happens when you can't
show up what happens if an employer says
when he told me exactly what happens New
Hampshire ball bearing anyone remember
when that
had a big explosion there
um they couldn't get enough people every
single fire department has Mutual Aid
that they can call in when they don't
have enough people
there's not one case that I'm aware of
where anyone has been fired
we're not showing up
I know what brought up on this bill
one situation up in the Lakes Region one
where you have an individual who is a
fire chief of a volunteer fire
department
he also works for the town
and the boss where he works for the town
doesn't like it
I'm sorry folks I don't make law for one
situation
we have not heard any information that
anyone was ever fired
so I do the best I could
to be able to say
yes you should be able to go
but the the owner of the company has to
at some point they have the ability to
say no
and if at the end of the shift
they get all the stuff can the computers
turned over the container is empty
everything's done
um then you can go ahead and go we have
our own representative here who's not
here today because he's plowing snow
um that's what he does his landscape
company yesterday he could not have
allowed someone to go to a fire
he thinks it would have been too
detrimental
I've done the best I can
to try to meet
somewhere between where the bill
presents
and what employers need
thank you
representative Edgington
thanks Mr chairman
um I will be opposing Amendment zero
nine seven nine I would like to call
everybody's attention to uh line 13 of
the amendment
um inserted by section one of the bill
inserting after the paragraph one or I
the following new paragraph and
renumbering the original paragraphs two
through four to read as three through
five respectively and that is where the
line goes in that the chairman
referenced at the beginning of which you
have to work period in advance of any
shift or work period the employer has
the right to inform the employee that
their presence during the shift is
necessary and the employee will not be
able to leave for an emergency call
without the consent of the employer my
read of this is that it does not change
the text in what becomes section three
as used in this section responding to an
emergency xiaomin responding to comma
leaving work to respond to comma
um
that sets up inconsistent language where
the employer has the right to say you
need to stay here and the employee has
the right protected by law
I guess to tell them cool story bro
um that that is a fatal fly in there
um
and I do want to touch on the discipline
piece uh as was mentioned earlier
um
part of the issue with not specifying
that there's a protection against
Progressive discipline is that you get
three reprimands for having to respond
to a call and then the fourth reprimand
is you know you accidentally knock over
a bucket of water and then oh well
that's the issue right there bye
um that's an issue that a lot of us on
this committee have a concern with
um
I I had expressed that concern earlier
um and again
the fact that
this doesn't allow somebody to respond
to a fire
um is very concerning for me based on
the anecdote that I referenced earlier I
understand that you know there probably
are situations where you're the one
employee that can manage something but
if somebody's life is at risk
in the instance of a fire or an
emergency medical situation I'm sorry
but if I have to pick between somebody
that's trapped in a burning building or
some software I'm going to pick the
person that's trapped in the burning
building that is non-negotiable for me
um there are things that I think that we
could have worked on
um I just this is a really hard Bill to
try to split the difference off because
as I referenced in a reply all last
night this bill was so well written by
both the sponsors and OLS that it is a
very delicate Jenga Tower and by
removing the wrong load bearing block
you run the risk of toppling it and that
is a concern here that I have with this
amendment as well specifically with that
flow issue and also referencing the
disciplinary issue
in section one so for those reasons I
will oppose this amendment
further discussion
I think I'd like to add something
um we had some discussion there that
implies the difference between the
volunteer who's out there to save a life
versus their other role as an employee
maybe stocks stacking boxes in the in
the back room
um you mentioned software as as an
example and it made me think of my own
experience some years ago I was working
for a large utility
on their software that ran their control
center in their distribution for one of
the major cities in the United States
part of keeping that software running
particularly during a crisis hot weather
other outages
meant that power was supplied to the
major hospitals to the police stations
to the fire departments
I know we can sit here and say oh all I
care about is saving a life but we don't
know what every single employer is doing
and when do decisions that we make
threaten life and safety because of of
what we've dictated
so I don't think it's as clear as as
black and white
I see representative adjutant wants to
respond thank you Mr chairman I while I
do understand your point
um I would like to provide a little
context based on my work experience
um as some folks know I'm a security
officer at Dartmouth Health in Lebanon
New Hampshire
um Dartmouth health because it's a dhmc
is such a huge campus we operate on a
dispatch system we have a Soc at the
main front of the hospital when you walk
in it's the door right on the left
um and each officer on shift has a radio
um
Dartmouth has a system of duress buttons
so in the back of your badge it's got a
little button and if an employee is in
danger they can push the button it'll
immediately go to our SOC and officers
are sent there
if a duress alarm goes off it
immediately goes out to every officer
and every officer is expected to respond
unless you are in the psych Zone which
is an area that we can't leave it
doesn't matter what you're doing uh
there is an expectation that all those
officers will respond to a duress alarm
sometimes it's an accidental push but
sometimes it means that medical staff is
actively being attacked by a patient
especially in some of our psych areas
um
those calls don't happen
um flippantly
they come across the tram uh because
there have been incidents in the past
where employees have been severely
injured and there wasn't a duress system
and that's why it's put in there
um likewise
if a call goes out to volunteer
firefighters it's not because the cat is
stuck in a tree
it is because a building is on fire or
somebody's life is at risk that is why
those calls go out
um yes if there was a world where a
volunteer firefighter was you know
called out because a fire hydrant is
leaking a little bit uh and they've got
a really you know important thing that
they're doing at work yes I could
understand that being the case as to why
you know it would make sense to have
somebody else do it or not let them out
but the fact of the matter is that when
you know code red comes over the radio
and you get an address there is an
expectation that somebody's life is at
risk or somebody's property is at risk
or something has risen to a degree where
it is imperative
that those people respond and that is
why
as I reference the bill is so well
crafted that the employer can request
verification from the fire chief that
this was a situation where uh life or
property was at risk and severe risk and
they need to verify that so
I don't want to flippantly dismiss
um other work as unimportant rather I
want to make the case that in a
situation where a volunteer firefighter
or an EMS person is expected to respond
is so incredibly critical to saving life
or saving property that I I really can't
justify another situation
um where that wouldn't be the case so I
will continue to oppose the amendment
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair I I I can't support
this amendment either but I think we
need to do more work on the bill to
gather more information from other
people who are involved and I was
missing both the last year when it was
introduced and this year we really
didn't get enough about
how the fire departments function what
you know and so I think we need more
work on the bill I would prefer to
retain it uh to then passing it with the
amendment or
or killing it
thank you
I'll go with representative love
thank you Mr chair uh I'll be supporting
this amendment um I think I think it's a
great compromise uh I I don't think that
we can uh continue to to take take
rights away from especially a small
business
owners
um you know if you've got five guys
working for you and you take one away
that that's a big chunk there's nothing
here in this bill that that stops IT in
fact as representative infantine
mentioned uh if it's if you've got 50
people working for you
and the one it guy has to go uh it could
shut down the business for the day
because of the fact that we do have
mutual Aid
and uh you know it that kind of takes up
the the slack
um you know we got to stop beating up
our small business owners you know uh it
I I fail to hear this a lot you know in
these in these hearings uh the the small
businessman owner in this state is you
know the the backbone of our our
industry and uh and and they deserve
some consideration here and I don't
think uh you know that the bill as
originally constructed uh gives the many
and the the amendment is a a good
compromise
thank you representative McKenzie
thank you Mr chairman
uh we we just heard from the
unemployment office about
the unemployment numbers in New
Hampshire and I think if the paper is
correct it was around three percent
which means that for the most part
people are working
and communities all throughout the state
there's very few people that are not
working
you have town after town after town who
relies on volunteer firefighters
and they have made that choice the
communities have made that choice to
have uh volunteer firefighters as
opposed to full-time firefighters and
EMS people that's a decision they've
made
now that that's where the rub comes down
for me whenever we talk about this stuff
if the the employees in communities
can't have it both ways
they're either going to fund the fund
money bring the money up and put the
money towards a budget that'll fund uh
full-time firefighters and EMS Personnel
or they're gonna they're gonna begin the
process of understanding that the only
way we're going to do this without
raising taxes is to allow people to go
uh from a lot of people out of work now
I think this is an important piece of
legislation I think it's something we
need to think about and work on I think
the concept of retaining makes some
sense
but the this is if if we take away uh
volunteer firefighters from the system
in New Hampshire we're in big trouble
and as somebody who spent 27 years on
the fire department and the biggest one
in the city of uh city of Manchester
we're in big trouble
because many towns don't have any
options and the concept that uh we're
going to allow Manchester fire to go to
Milford or Amherst to cover a mutual
weight
that's not going to last too long
because we're not going to spend our
resources uh from a big from a big city
to cover people who should be doing that
on their own and that's not to say we
wouldn't be there for the second
alignment third line but we're not going
to have firefighters crossing city
Alliance because you don't have
sufficient Fire Protection in other
communities I think this I think if we
would uh I'm not sure the amendment this
amendment meets it but I think the the
uh the concept is something that we need
to work on in this committee and we need
to find a place where everybody's
comfortable and employers need to be at
the table as well as uh as others in the
community so that we can uh we can come
to a consensus about how this is going
to work in our state of New Hampshire it
volunteer firefighters we've worked very
hard to bring the specs up you know they
meet certain standards they never had to
meet before they make a big investment
in their in their education and their
training and the communities benefit
from having those people there as do the
Employers in those communities they
benefit so we need to find some way to
to address this and work through these
decision
thank you
representative Cahill yes thank you Mr
chair I meant to add that you know one
of the things we could consider would be
an exemption for some number of
employees and under that you know that
would that would be acceptable but I
also think that as uh
uh representative Sullivan had mentioned
during the hearing most people would be
self-selecting and thinking that well my
job would not allow me to leave so
therefore I can't be the person to
volunteer on the fire department so
that's another thing to consider I don't
know that we're going to have the I the
one I T person or the person that's
supposed to fly the plane out of Logan
at 10 o'clock that day uh volunteering
to serve on the fire department but when
the people who can do it we think we
need to find a way that it works for
both sides of the equation
thank you
uh
representative vulgar sorry
thank you
um
and sitting here listening to this going
back and forth it
concerns me that if we passed such a
strict bill
that
says the employer can't do this the
employer can't do that does this now
create a situation where you've got a
small company and now the employer has
two candidates that they want to hire
and they obviously picked the other now
because this one's going to be
encumbered with such
uh
restrictions that would allow them and
hinder his ability to do work where
candidate Aid doesn't have any of these
encumbrance then
would that change the hiring mechanism
that is being done because now it might
be covered in another portion another
law forgive me for my ignorance in that
situation but based on what I've read
here
you're putting all the onus on the
employer
so they're going to end up making
decisions
about who they're going to hire and who
they're not going to hire
whether it be upfront or beside or
whatever reason you take those
encumbrance when you add these laws to
it will be there
thank you any further discussion
representative Sullivan
thank you
um rep Cahill just brought it up and I
was uh did want to emphasize that
um
people uh who decide to become volunteer
firefighters decide to do it because
they can they have a the type of
lifestyle and job that will allow them
to be able to do it
um so I I firmly believe and frankly I
would have liked to have been on you
know my Grantham fire department
um but my job just didn't have that kind
of flexibility I was I'm generally not
in town what good is a volunteer
firefighter who's uh hour and a half
away
um so um I think people
and that's part of the reason it's hard
to find volunteer
firefighters because basically there are
only so many people who have that kind
of flexibility in in their life to be
able to do it
um and um and for that reason I don't
think the um the ability to say no is
really that necessary because I think
the the employees have probably figured
out already that they can't uh handle it
with their particular job and there's
lots of jobs that don't mix well with uh
volunteer firefighting
um
and um
and and I I will also emphasize that the
um inability to uh or or the allowance
of disciplinary action is a real problem
if you can discipline someone each time
that they um go out on a call
um
you can't fire them for that but you can
discipline them over and over and over
again
and then there's some type of
transgression that takes place somewhere
down the line if it's your um your 10th
reprimand
um I can see employers deciding to use
the the nine
fire related rubber bands and the one
reprimand that's unrelated and
potentially to um take action against
the employee that's how Progressive
discipline Works
um
so and uh you know we've had a
discussion with uh the sponsor not the
sponsor but um both the sponsor of the
amendment that this isn't a union
situation it very well could be a union
situation
um we don't know what the job of these
folks the the
the paying job is compared to their
firefighting job
um many of them may
um or at least some of them may be
members of a union so um at any rate I'm
not going to be supporting this uh
Amendment
thank you further discussion
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
on Amendment
0979 h
uh Mr chair
yeah rep avaloni yes
Brett bogert yes
rep love yes rep Boyd yes
rep Mason yes Repco come yes
rep sellers yes
Repton yes
ranking Dem Sullivan no
rip Murray no
rep Cahill no
Reptil Lorenzo no
prep Susie no
no
rep adjectives no
Brett McKenzie no
the clerk votes no replicaair no
and Mr Vice chair yes
that is a 10 to 10 vote
so that Amendment does not pass uh
representative infantine do you have a
further amendment to bring forward I do
not okay I think I I saw that
representative Cahill may have a motion
I think the proper order is because we
have an OTP and no Amendment passed is
that the next motion is the OTP with no
Amendment
um representative abalone
did you have a community that option for
algebra
yes
shall move Mr chairman
second I didn't hear that so uh
representative avalani moved the motion
for OTP and it was seconded by Sullivan
um so do we have could I get clarity if
you OTP and if it ties you're dead if it
ties
still without recommendation at a
further motion would be in order at that
so would he be able to make a motion
with them at that point uh
right now and and I I probably should
have asked I was not aware of any other
amendments that had been prepared if I'm
wrong in that please correct me
um which is why we're voting on OTP with
no Amendment if this also ties then I
would look to representative Cahill
um
for a further motion to see if we had
something that would get a majority
of the members
representative adjutant
Mr chair can I defer to representative
Sullivan first
uh certainly representative Sullivan
thank you
um
I do believe this bill is ready to go
um I I think it uh in its original form
it does work it gives a job protection
that uh these volunteers uh do need and
I believe as presented this bill will
work just fine and so I would like to
see it uh pass
OTP and go to the floor
um as if presently uh
exists thank you
representative thank you Mr chairman um
I said it a couple times I'm going to
say it again I am very impressed with
how thoroughly this original bill was
written
um it's very rare
um that you get a bill that uh considers
all contingencies and I wanna
um give a shout out for the record to
our heroes in the office of legislative
Services who do this work they did a
really good job on this one as
representative Sullivan alluded to this
is a really uh good bill that's ready to
go now it deals with the issue of
progressive discipline uh leading
determination
um
I
I don't know what amendment we couldn't
make I I know there's hope that maybe
there's some hypothetical Amendment
um that could satisfy everybody
um unfortunately I think that's you know
the King Solomon Amendment
um on a bill as delicate uh and as well
prepared as this
um
it just it has all the protections and
uh I know everybody on the committee
received an email last night from a
gentleman named will Bateson uh will
Bateson was a colleague of mine at 25th
Marine headquarters or 25th Marine
regiment headquarters company
um we really are just providing the
exact same standards that exist in
userra
um that already cover our service
members like the ones that are failing
in the state prison right now that's why
this is so confounding to me because
there's this belief that this is this
brand new um set of Standards but in
reality this is what our National Guard
service members and uh Reserve members
already operate under essentially
um and I think that's great you know if
there were more volunteer positions in
our communities that would be uh
coverable under this I would have
submitted amendment to make it broader
um but I think this is a great way
um to encourage more volunteerism to
retain
um to meet in the middle with the issue
that representative McKenzie raised as
far as funding for our departments
um so I'm going to support the OTP I
think this is ready to go uh and I look
forward to a thorough discussion on the
floor when this comes up in the next few
weeks
representative colcom
I'm not in favor of the opt to pass on
this and I'm also not in favor of
comparing this to our federal government
military positions positions which do
not have an option to decline the
assignment that they're being um
taken out of the workforce for so if our
government is mandating that they must
report to duty that's different than a
volunteer firefighter where we do not
have government mandates
um so I don't believe that the two
should be compared
in this argument
thank you
further discussion
representative
thank you I don't think the bill is
ready
no one has been fired that anyone can
tell me
or no one has been disciplined out of a
job that anyone can tell me or show me
since this bill has not been in place
ever
um
you all know I grew up in a town
with volunteer firefighters and I
respect them immensely and I think
they're a very valuable part but what
really bothers me is the insult all the
time
to some of the people in this committee
that own businesses that we're rotten
and we're not going to work with someone
and we're not going to help
yet you can never believe that an
employee might abuse something
oh God forbid
so I try to present something that's
fair to both the employee and the
employer but that's not good enough
the employee needs
whatever breath they want
that's not right
that's not fair to either one of them
this is not a fair bill
I want to help
this isn't the one to do it
thank you
representative vagina
thanks Mr chairman
thank Mr chairman
um
just going to read section one uh really
quick no employer shall discharge or
take any other disciplinary action
against an employee by reason a failure
of such employee to report the work at
the commencement of such employees
regular working hours where the failure
is due to the employees responding to an
emergency in his or her capacity as a
volunteer member of a fire department or
ambulance department provided
however that no such employer shall be
required to compensate any such employee
for any period of such employees normal
working hours during which the reason
for the employee's failure to report for
work and at the request of the employer
shall submit a statement signed by the
chief of such fire department or
ambulance department certifying the date
and time such employee responded to and
returned from the emergency such
employees shall infer inform his or her
employer or immediate supervisor of the
reasons for the failure to report I
think and I I'm going to say it for the
fourth time and it's not just because
you know I want to give you some Pat On
The Backs
um
what we just heard as far as potential
employee abuse of that policy is defined
in here if the volunteer firefighter
goes to Cumby's and hangs out for a few
hours
and the employer says okay you know you
were on a fire I would like a you know a
written statement from your fire chief
saying you were on that fire well guess
what fire chief is not going to write
that the employee was at a fire if they
weren't
that's that's already that is so already
well thoroughly fleshed out in this bill
um I think it avoids those kind of
situations so I I agree with
representative Sullivan I think it's
ready to go
thank you any further discussion
seeing none with the clerk please call
the roll
this is a vote ought to pass on the bill
Mr chair no
rep avaloni no Brett bogert nope
love
nope rep Boyd no right Mason no
Repco come no
prep sellers no rep done no
ranking Dem Sullivan yes
rep Murray yes
rep Cahill no
prep De Lorenzo yes
represhard yes
repadjet
McKenzie no
the clerk votes yes
repliclair yes
and Mr Vice chair no
um that is eight years and uh 12 Nays
the motion fails
representative Cahill would you like to
make a motion uh yes I'd like to move
that we retain this bill
all right a nice uh representative
avalani with the second
he he tried he uh I I redirected away
from him when he tried to make the
motion so how about a close second
avaloni thank you
we'll make it a bipartisan motion
um and I see represent adjutant
thank you Mr chairman I strongly oppose
the retained motion
um
that we we've tried we've had this bill
for two months
um I
I don't think there's a magic Amendment
that's going to make everybody happy uh
and the fact of the matter is that in a
situation like that I'm going to uh side
with the rights and privileges of the
volunteer firefighters and EMS workers
um it's really disappointing uh I I
think we've had uh ample time to
negotiate and find a solution and we
just haven't so
um I don't know what holding on to this
for another six months is gonna do
um maybe I'm wrong I I don't know that I
am
um but I I I'm going to oppose this
retained motion
further discussion
I think everyone has said their Peace So
if the clerk would call the rule
on the motion to retain
um
Mr chair yes
Brett pavalani
rep bogert yes
reply yes
prep boy yes
rep Mason yes
Repco yes
prep sellers yes
rip done yes
ranking damn Sullivan yes
Brett Murray
no
rep Cahill yes
prep De Lorenzo yes
prep Susie yes
right Bouchard yes
Brett McKenzie yes
the clerk votes no replica yes
and then Mr Vice chair yes
17-3
all right thank you and that concludes
uh this bill I've fallen a bit behind so
I'll turn it back over to our chairman
to set things straight
okay
not yet
Jason
moving on to House Bill 82 FN
Poland representative Sullivan
for a motion
thank you Mr chair
um I move ought to pass and also move uh
an amendment
um and I passed these amendments out uh
at the outset of our gathering the
amendment is uh
2023-0785 h
m
would be swell to have a second
I'll second
moved by Sullivan second by
representative attitude
Mr representative Sullivan you're
recognized speaker anymore thank you
um
when we originally
um had the hearing for this bill
um the uh
sponsors and those supporting it were
quick to say that the bill as uh
originally presented was uh was flawed
and needed to be amended
um and so um
the um it's actually been amended twice
since then
um the first time
um the lines
13 and 14 were inserted
um which indicates that this section
shall not apply in cases where this
limitation conflicts with employers
obligations under federal law or
regulations or fulfilled or to fulfill a
federal contract or licensing obligation
and that addresses any concerns over the
fact that this is
technically not legal under federal law
so the people who are you know have for
example a trucking driver's license
would
it would this would not apply to them
in other similar Federal um
employment or federally licensed
employment
um
lines 15 and 16 were added at our last
subcommittee meeting and that
that section reads this section shall
not apply to employees of Emergency
Medical Services law enforcement Public
Safety officials in firefighter services
so this brings those
first responder type employment
um
it excludes them from
um from this bill
so the um those are the two substantial
changes that the amendment brings what
the bill itself does is it um assures
that
no employee will be
disciplined or discharged
solely because they have a medical
um a
therapeutic canvas card
um or because they
um they test positive for THC
what we heard in testimony is that THC
remains in a person's system for for
many many days after any type of usage
whether it's recreational or therapeutic
so essentially testing positive for THC
simply indicates that sometime in the
not too distant past but not necessarily
recent the person person has used
cannabis
um
testimony was also very clear that the
objective with therapeutic cannabis is
not to become intoxicated it's to deal
with the symptoms that are qualifying
under the under the law
um
the um
it's important to note that there aren't
that many people that have a therapeutic
a cannabis card
many of the people who have the card
aren't working
um so there's only a certain number who
are employed so the number of people
that this actually applies to is not
huge
um
but it is important to give them that
protection
and frankly it's protection that they
already have
this this New Hampshire Supreme Court
has decided that someone who is in the
therapeutic cannabis program is entitled
to accommodation in the workplace
that's been made clear what this bill
does is it takes that Supreme Court
decision and it puts it into statute
so that someone doesn't have to go to
court
um paying all the expenses that are
involved there in order to secure those
rights so um
this is not something new this is
something that the Supreme Court says
people are entitled to
um a lot of work has gone into this and
I firmly believe that this is a bill
um well worth supporting I would also
um point out that I handed out earlier
chapter 126x
that is the therapeutic cannabis statute
it's very important to read 126 x along
with the bill because 126x already puts
a lot of restrictions on an employee
who's in this program
an employee for example cannot
um
be under the influence of THC without
written permission from the employer
an employee cannot have cannabis at the
work site without written permission
from the employer
many of the people people in this
program
don't intend or need to use cannabis
while at work many people use it to for
example deal with pain at night so they
can get a good night's sleep and be
effective at work the next day
and so it's
it's
there are a lot of restrictions in 126x
that back up this uh this bill so um
I think this bill is
advantageous for the people who need it
and I urge your support thank you
representative um by love
I am not in favor of this amendment due
to three words the focus on the
conversation seems to always go to
terminate and disciplinary action of an
employee and what we seem to leave out
in a lot of our conversations are the
three words that are deny employment to
and
well I can understand the part about an
existing employee
if I work at a company and my employer
knows what my work ethic is what my
behavior is and they see that there's a
change in me because of my use of
cannabis then I can understand that
this business about being able to not
being able to deny employment is
completely different an interview
process you're getting the best of that
employee presumably during an interview
process and you're taking somebody on
good faith
an offer for employment
is usually contingent upon passing of a
drug screening for those companies that
do drug screening not every company does
but most I don't know of a single
company that does drug screening before
that offer is is offered out there
because if they start drug screening the
candidates that are applying they have
to drug screen every candidate that is
applying you can't pick and choose
candidates however when the job offer is
out you can choose to make that job
offer contingent upon a drug screen
this bill does not exclude electricians
it does not exclude any other high risk
positions we've been told to go back to
chapter 126x and look at what the
exemptions are there however the
exemptions here under under 126 x 3
Roman numeral two
they exempt any person from arrest or
prosecution for being under the
influence during operating a motor
vehicle so on and so forth but they
don't talk about the employer's rights
during this or the employees rights
during this this is just from arrest and
prosecution so you know we refer to
Roman numeral two as items that are
detailed that are excluded from this
that is actually not in the workforce
that's from arrest or prosecution
so I believe that we should at the very
minimum be removing the words deny
employment to and allow the employers
the option to make their own decisions
and if an employer does get a drug
screen back that does come back positive
for cannabis they should be entitled to
the right to sit down and talk with that
employee potential employee find out
what the circumstances are and to be
able to make a decision accordingly
and if I'm the employer which I have
been the employer of electricians an
electrician comes back positive for drug
screening I'm not hiring him the risk is
too great the risk is too great to my
workers comp the risk is too great to
him personally the risk is too great to
the job I don't think it's a responsible
thing to do and that's the decision that
I've made as an employer hiring several
electricians and HVAC service
technicians so I'm not in favor of this
amendment
I concur with representative colcum I I
spoke with the attorney from the uh the
insurance commissioner's office and uh
although they don't have a position on
the bill he sees a lot of these these
Insurance problems you know surfacing uh
in the future they haven't happened in
any other state yet
and the key word he said it is yet
um you know when If an employer says
it's it's okay for you to you know be to
have cannabis or or you know not be able
to pass a a test and say let's let's
take a warehouse position for instance
somebody can use a two-wheeler and move
cases of stuff around
but when he hops on a forklift
you know to move something and he
smashes into a into a a rack that's that
goes 20 feet high and that things start
uh tumbling down
um
you know and he's he's our the employer
has given him permission to work there
on its nest where uh we could be we
could be dealing with here and uh you
know the The Eternity at the attorney
more or less brought that up
um you know workers comp once again you
know representative colcum talked about
the uh the the uh the ramifications
there
um you know it we could be opening up a
real nasty can of worms here uh the
employer once again would take an
employer's rights away you know they're
the ones with the investment you know
many of them have you know have scrapped
and saved and worked 20 hours a day and
all the rest of it to build these
businesses and now we're going to take
rights away I I think that's wrong and
uh you know uh
I uh
I'm all for the uh the you know cannabis
as far as a uh as far as pain meds and
what have you but um you know we can't
be taking employers rights away plain
and simple you know they've got to have
to laugh the last say
you know um if um if they don't want
somebody that that can't pass a drug
drug screen that's that's their business
and um you know they're the ones that
are going to take the fall for it
they're the one and the bottom line is
you know the we uh we always blame the
guy at the top the guy at the top is the
employer in this case we can't do this
to them thanks
lo and behold before us stands another
well-written Amendment
um as was written or as was said
um the three words deny employment two I
would like to direct everybody's
attention to the one word in line eight
which is the word solely
as with most discrimination law you are
allowed to not hire somebody from a
protected class if that person has a
criminal record
you are allowed to not hire
um a person of a projected race class or
a protected gender class if there are
other things in that person's resume
that would preclude them from working
however
their race or their gender cannot be the
sole reason why you don't hire them and
that is exactly how this
anti-discrimination language before us
is written if a person comes in
um obviously impaired
um
you are allowed to not hire that person
this bill and this amendment
specifically pertains to people who want
to work and I want to make that as clear
as possible this is an enabling
Amendment for individuals who wants to
be able to provide for themselves to
have that opportunity to do so
um I also want to read line 17 and 18
because I think this is very important
to the last speaker's comments nothing
in this section shall be construed to
require an employer to allow being
impaired by cannabis products while at
work
in a hypothetical scenario where
somebody is driving you know a fork lift
and they're obviously messed up the
employer can the employer can let them
go the employer can send them home that
is not protected under this I we had the
same discussion in the public hearing
where we looked at the original context
of the bill and folks would say well you
know what if you smoke something at
lunch and then you climb up the
scaffolding that was not allowed in the
original version of the bill the
I I would the two big things that I
would take away from this amendment and
why I'm going to uh very much support
them are line eight uh solely because
and then the issues uh and then 17 and
18 provide very good protections to make
sure that there are no safety issues at
work
um
where an employee is not allowed to be
impaired again for the record nothing in
this section shall be construed to
require an employer to allow being
impaired by cannabis products while at
work I will be supporting this amendment
I think it makes a good bill even better
if you have a question of the uh
Amendment author I do and while I agree
with several of the previous speakers
points I never want to take
uh on face value that Amendment must be
perfect and I'm I'm concerned about one
word in here and somebody who was part
of the drafting maybe can explain it to
me
um section one A and B are separated by
the word or uh which to me that means
that it's either
a or b independent of each other and to
me it would seem like the intent is an
and that you're trying to
um protect someone who tests positive
while they have a card not test positive
or have a card so if someone's familiar
with this language more than I am and
understands
how it's constructed if you could
explain it I would appreciate it
representative Sullivan
I think it's important to look at the um
lines six through eight in conjunction
with that because lines six through
eight indicates that the person is a
qualifying patient who possesses a
current valid registry identification
card so um so basically that means that
um
everyone involved with A or B is a um
someone who holds the card so section B
where the individual has a positive drug
test that individual is part of the
therapeutic cannabis program
um so um frankly I had the same
difficulty at one point if you read a
and b
um in isolation it the or is a bit
troubling but if you read it in
conjunction with um lines of six through
eight it the problem is solved
and I'd like to thank the representative
for that explanation and for the uh
understanding that we we were both had
the same issue I I do understand and and
stand corrected thank you
followed by love
thank you Mr chairman
I have doubts with this uh Bill the
before I retired I worked in a
lumber department of a big box store
okay and in this lumber department you
moved around a lot of heavy material and
a lot of times this took teamwork you
had two people working with you to
coordinate the movement of this material
and as with firemen and as with a lot of
other things they rely on your partner
to make sure that you don't get injured
okay so if if someone's having an issue
and there's an oops and you have two
thousand pounds of lumber following you
then that is the noops that you can't
take back I doesn't matter if you tested
which way it doesn't come back
someone doesn't go home
if you're operating in a lot it's not
just happened to be forklifts forklifts
is the hierarchy of it but you have it a
lot of other mechanical assistant tools
that are used in these retail
environments that
you're working with customers close in
with it you're working with other people
close in you're working in narrow our
ways and stuff with this power equipment
which could have devastating
results if an oops
happens
so
I dare say if if someone's not on their
game
a hundred percent oops is not an if it's
a win
just when is it going to happen now I
don't know if anybody's ever saw a video
of Representative we're gonna we're
speaking on the amendment please yes
okay thank you
the effects of someone not being on
their game
could have some devastating effects
with that that's all I have to say thank
you
thank you Mr chair regarding
representative edgington's um comments
about uh you know not smoking a joint at
lunchtime
unfortunately and I really mean this
unfortunately we don't have the
capability of telling whether you know
you you smoke The Joint last night
oh you smoked it at lunchtime a five
dollar bottle of Visine
can can get you past the bus
okay your eyes aren't red anymore uh
you're certainly off your game
but your eyes aren't red
you probably even pass a roadside
sobriety test you know law enforcement
and all these cannabis bills
um of all you know expressed concern
about the inability
to test and and be and be able to stand
in front of a judge and and uh and get a
conviction with well I thought I I
looked kind of stone to me
you know we don't have the capability of
telling and uh you know I I just see you
know all kinds of industrial accidents
I've worked in you know in trades that
like uh you know the representative was
talking about that uh that this if
somebody isn't on their game part of the
team isn't on the game somebody could
very well get very hurt now I've got a
friend that lost his arm because
somebody wasn't on their game okay I
know of another guy that that rolled
over a forklift and pinned his leg to
the to the you know to the cement
underneath them and he wasn't on his
game okay uh you know in fact he he was
stoned he admitted he was Stone
um you know we don't have the capability
of testing
and I I wish that you know that I wish
I'd find a solution to that this
afternoon
but um you know as of right now
we're gonna have dangerous people doing
dangerous jobs and we won't be able to
stop them
thanks all right we are talking about
the Amendments on the floor
representative attitude thank you Mr
chairman the good news is that
um the amendment pertains to RSA 126x
colon four
um which highlights the very responsible
uh group of people that are presently on
the therapeutic cannabis program to talk
about how this amendment intersects
um with that and with the concerns
um about safety I think it's important
to highlight that there are many rules
and regulations that govern the
participation of the broader therapeutic
cannabis program uh in those people as
we heard in testimony
um are very aware that their
participation is a privilege and not a
right New Hampshire is very unique in
the rules that we place on those
individuals in order to continue to be
on the program uh and the testimony
alluded to the fact that they are all
aware of that and they are aware that at
any point if they mess up uh their
Privileges and their card can be revoked
I believe that puts a
comfortable enough chilling effect
um on any kind of shenanigans that could
lead to impairment as referenced in the
amendment
um so I am very grateful that while I
recognize the situation that the
previous speaker was mentioning we have
a lot of very responsible people on that
program and I want them to be able to
work I want them to be able to support
themselves and not have to be on the
well-functioning employment system that
we spoke about on another bill and this
is the path to do that
representative Leclerc thank you Mr
chair although I do agree with a lot of
the arguments about you know being
impaired and causing a potential safety
issue you know I'm in construction too
I've been in my whole life you know I
don't want someone impaired to set up a
staging like we had spoken about and
climb up in the air but
this right here and I've been on Plenty
of job sites where everybody gets drug
tested
as long as they could provide a card and
prove whether it's an opioid or cannabis
or what if they have a doctor's
prescription or a card
they're allowed to be there they're not
impaired
they're just taking what they need to
take to function during the day I think
the impaired part is
the key word in all this right if you
are impaired hell no get off my job you
don't need to be here
um putting other people at risk so I
think that right there is the big word
the impaired Park you know you have the
card you're legal you're within your uh
prescription and um that part really
needs to be considered thank you
okay
a lot of people I'll get to everyone as
best I can especially the ones that
haven't spoken first so let me see the
hands over here again
okay
represent Sullivan and ma'am I'm
representative uh
thank you representative Mary so
representative Sullivan McKenzie
thank you um I think it's really
important to look at 126x3
um to see what additional rights an
employer has
um nothing in this chapter shall be
exempt shall exempt any person from
arrest or prosecution for being under
the influence of cannabis
while in his or her place of employment
without written permission of the
employer if the employer has any
concerns about someone being under the
influence of cannabis they simply don't
give them the written permission
if they are under the influence without
the permission
they can be arrested so that's kind of a
big deal in addition I'm sorry represent
where are you reading on 126x yes 126x
and I'm looking at a section this is and
this is very difficult to read I will
acknowledge that I didn't write it
but basically I'm Roman 2
subsection a
number two
so Roman 2 a 2. so basically and in
basically there's there's three
different uh
um
circumstances there but I wanted to
point out the fact that you can't be
under the influence
without permission from the employer
written permission from the employer in
addition
um
this is hard okay here
um then section B under um two
B says the user possession of cannabis
by a qualifying patient or designated
care caregiver for the purpose other
than therapeutic use is permitted by
this chapter oh I'm sorry and then the
section c is the one I was looking for
the smoking or vaporation vaporization
of cannabis in any public place
including and again we follow down
um and
the um
number two D2 a place of employment
without the written permission of the
employer so basically
if if you are holding the card
and you have cannabis in your possession
and you want to smoke a joint during
lunch
you can be arrested for that and you
will lose your card so
um there are some very
um
important restrictions that 126x
provides for so um
that's why I passed it out you really
you shouldn't be reading the bill
without reading 126x as well because the
two are very much interconnected and I
would point out um Mr chairman that uh
the amendment is identical or the
amendment replaces the entire original
bill with the exception of the um uh
effective date so it's it the amendment
is the bill
thank you representative McKenzie thank
you Mr chairman there were two
references currently in New Hampshire
law
that refer to the issue of controlled
substances and and one of them is a
reference under the workers compensation
statute which refers to those people who
have a prescription for controlled drugs
and they're not considered to be uh
intoxicated intoxication means
intoxication by alcohol all controlled
substance as defined in our say 318b1
the definition shall not include any
employees use of a controlled drug for
which the prescription has been issued
authorizing such drug to be dispensed to
him
and secondly there is a reference under
318 B1 definitions which also refers to
the issue prescribed
um and you can I can provide that to the
committee the the issue is that if it is
a prescribed substance
uh and it's prescribed by a physician or
however we get to this the issue of uh
of how people get cannabis that there is
there are Provisions in the law that
address this that talk about this uh and
they've been in the law for some time
uh you can't go into a and I agree and I
I've had you know I've run companies I
run uh I was a firefighter for a long
time I had people under my under my
charge uh you know the difference
between somebody is intoxicated and
somebody uh who's not and you you
address that but the fact is that we are
putting cannabis in a very different
place than the other controlled
substances and the law addresses that
and they said if you have a prescription
form so the question I have I guess is
how is it that somebody that comes in uh
and the Cannabis is the issue and yet
you have all these other substances that
say you that that they are uh allowable
if you have a prescription so there's an
issue that I have about how we are we
discriminating against people who have
the right to have prescriptions that uh
whether it be controlled substances and
these are both in the law do we
discriminate against people specifically
because it's cannabis
because the law allows for people to be
on prescription drugs and to work and to
go to work and it happens every day I
could go to a dentist tomorrow they give
me uh oxy to get me over this this
routine and yet I go to work and the
doctor prescribes it and the doctor says
you have uh don't take more than this
and if you do you got to be in trouble
so it's a prescribed job just like
cannabis would be
it is a it is a uh a list of those kinds
of things that you would have access to
for a whole variety of things and there
are all kinds of people that we heard
from that that are out in the in the
business world today so if we're going
to start saying to employers well if
somebody comes in and they got cannabis
just because they put down cannabis
we're going to knock them out and then
if they put down other control
substances which are listed in under 318
we're going to knock them off for that
and we're going to knock them off with
this and we're going to knock them off
with that so where does it stop the law
says if it's prescribed it's allowable
and that's the point here and the law is
clear but that whether it be workers
compensation or the control Drug Act
thank you Mr chairman
welcome representative Murray
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to take
a moment to remind the committee
um of how hard it is to get a medical
card in New Hampshire excuse me because
there's been a lot of talk about
operation of heavy machinery
which I don't think anyone with a
medical card would be doing so if you
want to get a medical card the
conditions that are allowable are autism
moderate or severe PTSD moderate or
severe chronic pain severe pain that has
not responded to previously prescribed
medication or surgical measures and
opioid use disorder as far as I know
anyone with chronic pain is not going to
be working a heavy manual labor job that
is going to put other people at risk and
any other diagnoses also require
symptoms such as Alzheimer's
chemotherapy induced anorexia constant
or severe nausea these are all like
super physical
symptoms these people are not going to
be working jobs that are going to put
other people in danger danger while
they're on the job it's older folks who
maybe do not have enough on Social
Security to just live off of that and
they're taking you know cannabis to
treat their pain it's people like that
that we're trying to give them away to
still access employment while taking
their legally prescribed medication
and again the number of people that have
medical cards again because they're so
hard to get is very very low
thank you
welcome but the second I got other
people who are who are representative
colcum representative abalone
foreign thank you Mr chair
um I'm going to divert from my original
comment a little bit uh in response to
the the comments just made from the
previous representative I believe that
we did hear
um during our testimony that by one of
our own members that it was fairly easy
for him to get a card and in response to
representative McKenzie I think also we
heard during our testimony that there is
no prescription for cannabis and there
is no doctor that is following the use
of or prescribing or following the use
of medical I'm sorry therapeutic
cannabis with any patient today that
that's not part of our law so to compare
this again to the prescriptions that are
being issued and being overseen by
doctors I think is
not pertaining to this but I want to go
back to my original comment
regarding this amendment and that the
the deny employment to is an important
piece for me because as an employer you
don't know the work ethics of people you
don't know the habits of people and for
me as an employer to think that somebody
is
in need of therapeutic cannabis
because they are
dealing with anxiety or discomfort or
pain and opioids are not handling this
and they've transitioned over it would
be very naive of me to think that they
can get through an eight or ten hour day
a 10 hour shift without needing to use
cannabis and I realized that that you
know that would have to be disclosed but
again hiring a new employee that I know
nothing about their work ethic and I'm
going on good faith based off of an
interview process excuse me process I I
struggle with that and that's the of
this entire Amendment those three words
are my reason for voting against this
um and nothing that has been said here
today is swaying me away from those
three words
of Alani followed by Cahill
thank you Mr chairman um having sat in
on some of those meetings and
participated in some of the conversation
which I always appreciate
um
from the subcommittee
we heard medical cannabis is not
prescribed
um so it wouldn't fall under the
prescription
um guidelines or rules that would fall
under the protections for prescription
drugs
um also there is no in the amendment
there is no Provisions for a religious
objection any Zero Tolerance policies uh
drug-free zones and there's no
definition of impairment to allow an
employer to make an adequate decision on
whether an employee is impaired or not
impaired and there was lots of topics of
conversation of whether any
test can be
allowed for that or any benchmarks like
we have for intoxication as being 0.08
or some type of intoxication for
cannabis while in the while being
employed and lastly for Section
um for the sponsor of the amendment for
Section colon
for part two section two in his or her
place of employing with our written
permission of the employer if the
written permission is not given by the
employer is the employer now denying
employment to
um
that employee because they did not give
their written permission
they were actually asking a question to
reservatory all those questions
because
we're always respectful here
um I'll kind of break the chain here
before I go to representative Cahill and
allow website if you'd like to answer
one of those questions
thank you Mr chairman
um I would like to point out that the
um
line in 126 x colon 3 that talks about
the therapeutic cannabis program starts
off on Roman two nothing in this chapter
shall exempt any person from arrest or
prosecution from going down to section c
the smoking or vaporization of cannabis
in any public place including a public
bus or other public vehicle or a public
park public beach public field
the possession of cannabis in any of the
following a building grounds of
preschool Elementary School Secondary
School which are located in the area
designated as a drug-free zone or a
place of employment without the written
permission of the employer there's a lot
that's already covered in 126x I don't
know if it would be appropriate to have
a little uh self-silent reading time
um to check that out but I I appreciate
representative Sullivan printing that
out and bringing it because I think
there are a lot of questions that are
answered in this debate by checking out
some of the language in there
Mr chairman may I well considering I
don't think the last set two sentences
where I gave you a courtesy were
appropriate sure
thank you Mr chairman uh there are a
number of drug-free zones besides
schools
um
police departments would be one of the
fire departments could also be another
one drug B loans so um saying that I can
unable to read the bill
um is kind of offensive no we're done
we're done representative Cahill
thank you Mr chairman
uh
I'd like to point out that when you are
hiring someone and you require a a drug
test and they pass it this could very
well be because they had abstained for a
period of time knowing that they were in
the job market and a drug test was
likely and upon you know getting their
first paycheck they could go out and buy
some cannabis as I'm told is a very
popular here in New Hampshire
um so I'm not sure how much protection
you're getting unless you're going to
test somebody every day which would be
expensive
um the other piece is I mean I'm
familiar with I have my wife's cousin
was in a terrible car accident uh he had
all sorts of surgeries and and pain
medicines and was really having a very
miserable life until he got a uh the
medical therapy card and he takes a
couple of drops before he goes to bed
and his life is much better he doesn't I
don't think I don't even know that he
will drive if he's feeling a little bit
you know stoned from this which I doubt
he would the next day so it's something
that people understand the
responsibility much like when you have a
prescription that says take two of these
don't take four you know you kind of on
your own to be responsible and I think
someone who shows up with it with the
card and says I've got this problem that
a doctor has approved this card and I
can do this work and I'm not gonna it's
not gonna interfere with safety or
anything like that the person is really
demonstrating that they're being
responsible by coming in and telling you
they have the card they don't even have
to do that they could just come in and
greet you in the interview and take the
test and whatever you want to do
demonstrate their ability show you the
resume they don't have to mention the
card they're being upfront and saying I
have a condition that I benefit from
because I have this card
uh also going back to an earlier time I
remember
a colleague who was driving a forklift
truck ran over the foot of the head of
the Safety Committee
and nobody was stoned it's just
accidents happen
thank you Mr chairman
I'm representative seaworth followed by
representative look
thank you Mr chairman I wanted to make a
point several Representatives have
brought up the fact that there aren't
prescriptions for medical marijuana
and I I think it's important just in
case our federal representatives are
watching our debate here today I'd like
to point out that this is a problem
created by the federal government
and we're stuck with trying to work it
out we heard this during testimony
marijuana cannot be prescribed because
it's a schedule one drug and there is no
nothing you can do with it legally at
the same time the federal government
kind of looks the other way and
you know allows what's going on with
medic marijuana to happen leaving our
committee in this situation where we
can't win either way
um so I wanted to make that point yes if
it were opiates
um the law would be able to deal with
the situation because it's marijuana
all the protections that are in place
both for employer and employee
fail because of the way the federal
government has classified this substance
thank you
look
thank you Mr chair and if I may add to
that there was no way to uh to medically
supervise uh
um this uh
this program
um also uh you know we we talked about
Job classifications in the amendment in
the summon title 10
um you know there's a half a dozen maybe
I I think if we sat here we could go on
for days
and figure out different job
classifications that's what the lawyer
from the insurance commissioner his
office said it would have to you know in
detail
every single classific job
classification and uh when would for
sure would leave a few out and uh and
that once again opens that proverbial
can of worms
um I've also heard that uh you know if
you have a couple joints in your pack of
cigarettes you could be arrested and not
in the state of New Hampshire you can't
you know possession onto three quarters
of an ounce of violation like spitting
on the sidewalk okay you'll get a ticket
that's it
um in um
the the medical marijuana bill we passed
last week allows for possession of up to
eight ounces plus
um the uh the the juvenile plants that's
a half a pound of pot
okay um
all this stuff doesn't jibe to me you
know it uh you know there's uh there's
just too many holes in this uh we've got
to protect employers from losing their
shirts and you know in the litigation
end of this once again you know there's
going to be litigation
um you know and to to jeopardize uh you
know somebody's life work
uh
isn't right they've got to have the last
call the last say thanks members of
management followed by Mackenzie thank
you Mr chairman I just want to uh say
out loud and for the record because I
don't think anybody else heard me um I
apologize uh to any member who
misconstrued my previous comments in a
disrespectful manner this has just been
a very long debate and I briefly lost my
patience
um so I just want to uh say that for the
record
thank you representative
thank you thank you
thank you
I just um it will be appropriate I would
just like
um my colleague who's talking about
um
you know
pre-employment uh
issues around the issue of drugs and how
was that how do you square that with uh
with the other substances that are
prescribed uh and and how how is that
distinction how do you make that
distinction
is it clear what I'm I'm messy is that
appropriate Mr chairman
um
I'll allow the question if you'd like
the answer representative I'm happy to
answer it
this bill is not addressing the other
the other drugs that are prescribed by
doctors and this bill is not restricting
employers from making a decision based
on those other drugs
and for that reason I have a problem
with the fact that it is pulling out
this one drug to be a protected drug in
the hiring process
so for that reason
I I find an issue with it and I don't
feel that we're giving the employers the
latitude to make the decisions
representative sellers followed by
representative Sullivan thank you Mr
chair
you know one time I did own a small
business and in any case here
if this line on line six it says no
employer
shell deny employment all right I mean
we're affecting thousands of businesses
here in New Hampshire
I mean and you're telling them that they
can't deny somebody because they're on
this therapeutic drug or what happens if
they do say you know what I'm going to
take a chance from this person I'm going
to hire them
now the next part of that sentence says
uh
they could terminate the employment off
so they can't terminate the person even
if they after they hire them so now
they're stuck you know at this point I
mean if you want to change the word
shout out to me maybe you got something
going for you
it was up Sullivan followed by
representative infantine
um I think it's important to note that
um
the uh following that no no employer
statement it says solely because and and
that's the the important piece so can
you fire the um someone who's got a
therapeutic cannabis card absolutely
just not solely because they've got the
card
um if if they're a bad employee fire
them
um you just have to um you may have in
some setting have to um so show some
proof that they actually are a bad
employee but the bottom line is
um this only protects people
solely because they are test positive or
solely because they hold a card that's
it
um so um and the other thing I wanted to
re-emphasize I said it way back in the
beginning and it's been a long hearing
um
Scott Payne versus right-of-way
Incorporated
argued October 14th opinion issued in
January January 14 2022 that is the New
Hampshire Supreme Court case that
provides that some was someone is
entitled to accommodation for their use
of cannabis under the therapeutic
cannabis program so
we need to we need to remember that the
Supreme Court has already decided on
this
this statute simply helps someone from
not having to go back to the court
system to enforce their rights to
accommodation under the therapeutic
cannabis program
there's the rights they already have
we're not giving them anything that they
don't already have thank you
I want to move this along we have an
amendment I'd like to vote of the
amendment uh it may surprise some of you
that representative Sullivan and I talk
and sometimes we agree and we we agree
more than we disagree and sometimes we
make agreements to do things
because it's the best for either a piece
of legislation or something moving
forward to get something done
and I have
told representative Sullivan I will
support his Amendment
today I have issues with the bill
overall which I'll speak about if this
amendment passes
but this takes
um
some of the issues with
um with the original bill that's not
perfect but it takes a lot of those
things and makes them better
so I will be supporting
the amendment and I'll come back
afterwards depending on how this um
follows to discuss some of the other
parts of the bill but um I just wanted
people to know that we actually do
come to agreement when we can on things
agreed to make things
move because ultimately
um
there are a lot of times we will
disagree but ultimately want to get a
bill passed so that being said if
there's not a lot more discussion I'd
like the clerk to to consider calling
the role the motion on the floor has
been moved and seconded there's been
some discussion unless I see any other
last minute comments I'd like the clerk
to call the role if you're in favor of
the amendment you'll be voting yes if
you're opposed to be voting no Clerk
Amendment zero seven eight five H Vice
chair seaworth yes
rep avaloni no
rep bogert
yes
rep love
no
repoid oh
rep Mason no
Repco come no
rep sellers
yes
rip done yes
ranking damn Sullivan yes
rep Murray yes
rep Cahill yes
rep Delorenzo yes rip Susie yes
represhard yes
right by adjutant yes
Brett McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
replica yes
Mr chair
yes
that's fifteen to five so the amendment
has to pass
um and the bill is open for uh
additional consideration are there any
other other are there any other
amendments to be brought forth
seeing none of whether motion
representative Sullivan
I move
otpa ought to pass as amended
and has been seconded by
I'm taking my representative soucy
it would have been made and seconded uh
your
um
recognize the speaker motion
um I'll keep it brief we've beaten this
one nearly to death
um the um
as I said a little while ago the
amendment replaces the entire bill with
the exception of the effective date so
and when we have been discussing
um the bill
um I believe it's a good bill
um I think as I said a minute ago it
simply puts in statute rights that
people already have by way of New
Hampshire Supreme Court we
ought to pin that down thank you
thank you representative Colt colcum
uh I will repeat myself but try to keep
it brief I am not in favor of ought to
pass I will be voting against this
um
cannabis is still a not legal at the
federal level and we should not be tying
our employers hands with a job offer to
force them to hire somebody that may be
a risk to their employment or to their
their business and um
I'll leave it at that
am I miss him
um
I am a supporter of therapeutic cannabis
use
um
for a lot of reasons I know how it's
helped individuals
former state representative who's a
friend of mine who was one of the
individuals who was worked very hard on
this bill
um
I I sat down with him last Friday night
it cost me a couple beers but it was
worth the conversation
and one of the things that disturbs me
is you you when you get your
allotment because we can't call it a
prescription
that's what it is for the month
and you can use it as you kind of see
fit
and I asked him well were you under the
influence
and when you would when you would go to
work and it goes well of course I was
um
to what degree
I don't know
uh so he wasn't sure
uh I have had three deaths uh while I'm
been an insurance agent and uh all of
them were big workers compensation
messes because all of them had marijuana
in their bloodstream
um what happens in the real world when
when an accident happens
is that blood tests are taken especially
when someone's severely injured or
killed
and then it becomes a big liability
problem for everybody all over the place
um
and that that really concerns me
um the Supreme Court case
really great read I I really hope a lot
of you read that I really also hope a
lot of you read
126x3 and if you haven't
um
you're missing out on something it's
it's really important and now
information to have but since we have a
resident Supreme Court Justice in our
midst uh in the house session last week
I asked him to read the bill
I'm gonna ask them to give me his
opinion
and he said yes it is a reasonable
accommodation
for
PTSD
it didn't say
that you're entitled to hire somebody
and you it can't be this whole reason
it said it was a reasonable
accommodation
okay for for to be able to use it okay
we have two different issues here one is
basically saying you you can't be the
sole purpose that you deny the nothing
that's silent it's not even discussed in
the Supreme Court ruling
um
the
the fact that you're not allowing
certain companies
to say no
we don't allow that here I have a
problem with
because the amendment which I just voted
for
if I'm going to be consistent
excludes
Emergency Medical Services law
enforcement Public Safety firefighters
why
why do they get it
because their bosses wanted it hey I'm
right there with you I agree
okay I'm not saying I disagree
but why can't I
as a business owner but they can
Federal contracts I agree has to be in
there why it's against the law
Federalist against the law
so we've given certain carve outs for
some but not all
we're using a Supreme Court
ruling that says this
and it's right
that Supreme Court ruling by our law
section 126 X3 is right
they got it right
doesn't say though
you can get solely
hire someone because they're have that
card
I wanted I advocated I lobbied to get
this retained
not because I'm trying to waste time
but as we've seen today some things are
really close
this is very close
but there's but you can't give it to
some and not the others
and as soon as you added the exclusions
for other people
and not the others what have you done
so I
with a heavy heart I will not support
the final bill
something close to it is the right thing
to do
but I don't feel this is the right one
yet
any other hands up
representative kale
thank you Mr chair I I understand your
concerns and I also understand the
concerns of people who would want to
exclude those people who are excluded
but I wonder if this is something that a
situation where we would let uh
we would let this the other body try to
work that out because it is so close in
in your mind that something that we
should allow to to go forward
if that if that had been afforded to me
um on other things I would have done
that but we we have a job here to do it
and I'm going to do it and and um
and uh my opinion this is what I think
could happen you know just let's not
talk about policy let's talk about
politics
all right
this is going to come out here 10 to 10
probably
so they go to the house floor
who knows
the house overwhelmingly passed
marijuana
a couple weeks ago they may be right
along with this one don't know
then it goes to the Senate
I how divided the house is how divided
the committee is how it goes to the
Senate versus coming out of the house
unanimous on the consent
I don't know what's going to happen over
there we all know what happens with the
Senate at the end of the term
we're going to yank a budget out we're
going to send it over to them are they
going to have time to want to deal with
it I don't know
that's the that's the
that's the political realization of a
situation we're in
I would rather we get it done right
and I'm not trying to kick this can down
the road
we have made agreements at OSHA I'm not
saying we made agreement on this but
representative Sullivan and I have
agreed
um that OSHA is very close
um he hasn't agreement on this one but I
feel the same way on that on this
um you got to take a couple things out
and you gotta
um put a few things in
um
so
you know as far as I'm concerned
whatever the committee wants to do the
committee is going to but my vote today
unfortunately is going to be no
representative Susie
just clarification so we'll get the odd
to pass as amended if that doesn't
succeed
can we still make the motion to retain
I will okay I'm not going to go with the
Ito
Representatives
um
love
just a clarification uh Mr chair you uh
you mentioned about a a monthly
allotment and we just passed a bill
that's going to allow eight uh eight
ounces of marijuana to be in your
possession uh that fire exceeds any
monthly allotment is I'm just guessing
that that would
um and also we've heard testimony about
um you know that marijuana can be uh it
can be engineered to to work on one
disease and not get you high and of that
high or whatever and uh because we
passed this bill and it's going to be
allow allowed for homegrown uh so the
the engineering of uh of the Cannabis is
not going to take place uh once again
this can of worms that we're opening up
uh I I can't I can't vote for it
manager
okay Mr chairman I would disagree with
the idea that the bill is very close I
happen to believe that it's there
um
like I referenced earlier it has the
same language that pertains to all other
uh non-discrimination bills
um the a lot of our civil rights
legislation in the United States doesn't
say you have to hire ex-member of a
protected class it says you can that
member being a protected class is not
the reason why you can't hire them if
there are other factors then you're not
allowed to hire them we've had the
discussion about Job performance you
know if somebody drives a forklift into
a wall
um or performs uh their job not well
that is subject for termination it just
can't be the sole reason is that they're
a card carrier or they have a positive
drug test for cannabis
this bill we've had for two months the
bill went to a subcommittee I think the
subcommittee had a good look at it this
amendment was produced
um so I would hope that we could uh send
it ought to pass in lieu of a retained
motion
okay last
uh there's a motion on the floor
ought to pass with Amendment
has been made by representative Sullivan
seconded by representative Susie had the
discussion if you were in favor of the
bill as amended you will be voting yes
if you're against you'll be voting no
clerk please call the roll Vice chair
seaworth no
rep avaloni no
no prep program no rep love
no
rip Boyd no
rep Mason no
Repco no
rep sellers no rip done no
face I'm sorry ranking damn Sullivan yes
Brett Murray yes
Repco yes
yes
Brett McKenzie yes
the clerk votes yes replicaair yes
and Mr chair
no
that is a 10 to 10 oh
representative Susie
you have a motion
yes sir Mr chairman uh motion to retain
of course on the floor is a retained so
I can play for some sushi I assume
representative Sullivan
I was at a Susie you have the uh uh you
recognize speak your motion thank you Mr
chairman so I sat on the subcommittee
um
and it was some great conversation
um between the four of us and we had a
few days where we had a couple other
people
um
I would agree that I think this bill is
very close and I'm going to say this
because
um
but not that I think we should do other
things or do this because other places
do it but there's 25 States
that currently do this
um so I think somewhere along the line
I think we can find a solution to help
the people that are on therapeutic
cannabis um
program and I look at it and some of the
conversations that we had during the
subcommittee
and I kept re-emphasizing the fact that
I understand everybody's opinion and I
respect everybody's opinion but I don't
really think that the people in the
therapeutic cannabis program
and not all there may be some but I
don't believe it's people that are
trying to abuse marijuana because I can
tell you in New Hampshire
if you want marijuana you can go to the
three states surrounding us
you don't have to get a therapeutic
cannabis card so it is everywhere
um do I think the bill that you know the
legalization is going to happen here who
knows but at the end of the day I truly
believe that therapeutic cannabis
program is to alleviate some of the
anxiety of people that may have
um may use opioids and are trying to get
off
using those opioids and this may be a
better way for them to do it and I you
know I understand people's feelings and
anxieties toward you know what happens
at work 29 years in a fire service seen
many many accidents DWIs uh accidents
that were caused by alcohol accidents
caused by drugs
um
if anybody in here thinks for one second
that this is not happening right now
um I have news for you it's happening in
almost every industry
um out there
so retaining the bill I think is a good
idea I think it needs some tweaks I
think we can work on it like I said if
25 other states across the country can
do this I think New Hampshire can find
some uh Common Ground between all of us
to uh try to get a good bill passed
thank you Mr chairman
foreign thank you Mr chairman I'm going
to oppose retaining I just want patience
of the therapeutic cannabis program to
be able to go to work uh and support
themselves because the alternative is
they're going to end up on the state
unemployment system and
um I
I would just oppose retaining
uh Madam Clerk thank you Mr chair
um I'm gonna join him in that vote uh no
because I think that it should go to the
house floor
uh with no recommendation
I agree with um there was a
representative Susie
that people on
therapeutic cannabis are not abusers
they are in pain
they have issues
um
I wish my dad had it as he died of a
terrible cancer
so I'm in favor of it
but we do need to tweak it and I will
support
but you make a valid very valid point
we want these people to be able to work
and right now by the Supreme Court
ruling they can work
they can get a reasonable accommodation
it would be great to put it in law
to help them out even more
I hope we can do that in
over the over the summer months
seeing no other hands if you're in favor
of the retain the pill you vote Yes if
you're oppose you won't know Madam Clerk
Vice chair seaworth yes
repavalani
rip bogert yes I love yes wait yes
rep Mason yes
Repco yes
rep sellers yes
rip done yes
ranking Jim Sullivan yes
Brett Murray no
rep Cahill no
Pepsi Lorenzo
yes
rep Susie yes
rip adjutant
we're at McKenzie yes
the clerk votes no Ripley clear yes
Mr clerk I mean Mr chair
Mr chair
sorry for that promotion momentary thank
you
is that says 16-4
is there any other business to come in
front of this committee
thank you very much for your thoughtful
and respectful uh testimony today people
representative I did have one question
did we put anything on the consent
calendar this afternoon well routine
retained bills are retained there's
nothing to go in the cassette what we
will be doing is
um representative Sullivan and I are
going to get a early jump on this so
there will be retained meetings
um prior to the summer correct as soon
as my this is my guest representative
Sullivan we're going to get two
bills from the Senate maybe three
the goal is to have one session
come back two weeks later kind of an
executive session
and in the meantime representative sold
I will be picking the the people to meet
um if they want on either a subcommittee
or whatever how we're going to deal with
these bills because
to take some time and if the speaker
doesn't want us to meet
July and August or whatever we're going
to meet beforehand a number of times
all right
representative avaloni thank you Mr
chairman just to request could we have
some of those meetings uh while we're
here in Concord uh during our committee
visits we start right after we get our
Senate bills yes thank you
I would be happy to volunteer football
okay thank you everyone
okay and then the clerk you need
foreign